son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
momento histórico previo a la Cumbre del
g20 en Bali yo by the sostuvieron su
primer encuentro los líderes rebajaron
las tensiones pero mantuvieron sus
diferencias sobre Taiwán She dijo a
biden que se trata de una línea roja que
no debe cruzar
avanzan las investigaciones tras el
atentado en Estambul medio centenar de
presuntos vinculados fueron detenidos
entre ellos la principal sospechosa que
según la policía habría sido entrenada
por milicias 6 personas perdieron la
vida y más de 80 resultaron heridas en
la explosión ocurrida en una transitada
calle
hace alrededor de dos meses Cuba aprobó
en referendo el nuevo código de familias
una legislación impulsada por el
oficialismo que por primera vez avala
Los matrimonios homosexuales y amplía
los derechos para La minoría trans
revisamos el impacto de esta normativa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos en la isla de Bali en
Indonesia donde inició la Cumbre donde
mañana inicia la Cumbre del g20 y hoy
tuvo lugar el encuentro entre los
presidentes de Estados Unidos
quienes estuvieron su primer encuentro
como mandatarios dicha reunión estuvo
enfocada en rebajar la atención entre
las potencias económicas pero dejó en
evidencia críticas a Beijing en materia
de derechos humanos y advertencias a
Washington sobre la línea roja que
atravesarías y Se involucra en temas
relacionados con Taiwán
evitar que la competencia se convierta
en el conflicto más temido fue la
premisa del primer cara a cara del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
su homólogo chino chilling Pink
creo que el mundo Espera que China y
Estados Unidos desempeña en papeles
clave y aborden los desafíos globales
desde el cambio climático hasta la
alimentación y la seguridad
la situación actual que enfrenta la
relación entre China y Estados Unidos es
una preocupación para todos nosotros
las relaciones entre ambos países están
en uno de sus peores momentos en décadas
por lo que los mandatarios hablaron
durante cerca de tres horas entre los
puntos principales estuvo Taiwán
territorio que Beijing considera una
provincia Rebelde y que ha prometido
reunificar así sea por la fuerza la isla
goza del apoyo económico y militar de
Washington silimpin avisó a byden de que
no cruce lo que para china es una línea
roja este respondió
[Música]
yo creo que haya un inminente intento de
China de invadir Taiwán
también está la situación en la región
de Asia Pacífico Estados Unidos promete
reforzar su posición en la región si
china no actúa para contener los
programas armamentísticos norcoreanos
mientras que china no esconde su
molestia por la alianza aucus que dotará
de una flota de submarinosa propulsión
nuclear Australia otro punto de
conflicto es la lucha comercial desde
Estados Unidos piden a sus empresas
reducir su dependencia de China mientras
que desde Beijing protestan por las
restricciones al acceso de productos
tecnológicos la guerra en Ucrania contó
con un punto de consenso
discutimos la agresión de Rusia a
Ucrania y compartimos la misma visión de
que el uso de armas nucleares es
totalmente inaceptable
los dos mandatarios llegan reforzados en
sus países vaiden tras retener el senado
en las elecciones de medio término y
Sheen Pink tras ser elegido en el
congreso del partido comunista
legitimidad con la que deberán decidir
si reconducir sus relaciones o seguir
por el camino de una peligrosa escalada
el presidente de Ucrania boludimir
selensky viajó hasta la ciudad de gerson
donde se celebró junto con los
residentes la retoma de la urbe y
decenas de localidades de la región
homónima esto al tiempo que la asamblea
general de la ONU aprobó una resolución
en la que pide Rusia Que responda por
los crímenes cometidos en los meses de
guerra y solicita que Moscú pague por la
reconstrucción de las zonas destruidas
con la bandera ucraniana ondeando de
nuevo el presidente bolodimir zelenski
llegó para celebrar lo que ha sido una
de las mayores victorias de Ucrania en
la guerra hasta el momento la retoma de
gerson
capital regional que los rusos habían
ocupado desde el 2 de marzo pocos días
después del inicio del conflicto
[Aplausos]
Este es el principio del fin de la
guerra porque ya ven nuestro fuerte
ejército estamos avanzando paso a paso
por nuestro país por los territorios
temporalmente ocupados por supuesto es
una pena que el camino sea largo y
difícil
el 11 de noviembre Celestia anunció La
retirada de las tropas rusas y que
ejerzó volvía a estar bajo el control
ucraniano un logro que se debe en gran
parte a la ayuda proporcionada por la
otan y los aliados occidentales de kiev
que le han suministrado artillería y
misiles de alta precisión y que todo el
mundo celebró en gersono no obstante las
autoridades ucranianas han pedido
precaución y han dicho que todavía no es
seguro volver a la ciudad ya que los
rusos podrían volver a atacar y la zona
está plagada de minas
el precio de esta guerra es muy alto
muchas personas resultaron heridas y
muchas murieron creemos que nuestro
ejército rodeó al enemigo y los rusos
estaban en gran peligro hubo una lucha
feroz y este es el resultado Hoy estamos
en gerson
Y es que esta guerra ha dejado a gerson
en ruinas con necesidad de ayuda
humanitaria y bombardeos que aún se
escuchan Rusia asegura no haber perdido
ni uno de sus 30.000 soldados y que La
retirada solo es parte de una
reorganización estratégica tras la
visita de celenski El kremlin dijo que
jerson sigue siendo rusa ahora el río
nieper actúa como frontera entre los dos
bandos de la guerra
en Turquía las autoridades avanzan en la
investigación del atentado ocurrido este
domingo en Estambul en el que seis
personas perdieron la vida y más de 80
resultaron heridas medio centenar de
sospechosos de estar vinculados con los
hechos han sido detenidos entre ellos
una mujer Siria que según la policía
sería la principal involucrada el
gobierno de ankara culpó a milicias
kurdo sirias del ataque
la principal sospechosa en manos de las
autoridades una mujer kurdo Siria es
señalada de ser presuntamente la autora
del atentado que se saldó con varios
muertos y decenas de heridos en Estambul
la persona que llevó a cabo el incidente
la que dejó la bomba ha sido detenida
por la policía de esta noche Turquía
culpó las milicias kurdas de gpg en
covani una ciudad del norte de Siria que
es objetivo militar de los turcos no
obstante el líder kurdo de la región más
de un abdi ha negado cualquier
implicación
afirmamos que nuestras fuerzas no tienen
nada que ver con el atentado de Estambul
y rechazamos las acusaciones que acusan
a nuestras fuerzas de ello expresamos
nuestras más sinceras condolencias a las
familias y al pueblo Turco y deseamos
una pronta recuperación a los heridos Y
es que Turquía sostiene que las milicias
kurdas de Siria son un grupo terrorista
con vínculos con el partido de los
trabajadores de kurdistana pkk enemigo
del ejecutivo Turco algo que ha tensado
incluso sus relaciones con Estados
Unidos
rechazamos las condolencias de la
embajada estadounidense no las aceptamos
nuestra Alianza con este estado que
envía dinero de su propio senado para
estos grupos fomentando los grupos de
Cobán y que quieran perturbar la paz de
Turquía está en una situación
controvertida
a pesar de que la autoría del crimen
Todavía no se ha esclarecido el atentado
ha causado conmoción en el país y miedo
a que este tipo de ate se conviertan en
algo habitual de Cara a las elecciones
de junio de 2023 en las que receptogan
podría perder por primera vez tras dos
décadas en el poder
en Israel el regreso de Benjamín de
cargo de Primer Ministro hace saltar las
alarmas entre la oposición tras los
resultados de las Quintas elecciones en
menos de 4 años de tan Yahoo recibió
oficialmente ayer el encargo del
presidente Isaac gersog de formar un
nuevo gobierno los aliados de netanyahu
son los Ultra nacionalistas y los Ultra
ortodoxos con este panorama los
palestinos ven más lejos que nunca una
salida negociada a la ocupación Andrés
granadillo tiene los detalles
la vuelta de Benjamin de tanyahu al
gobierno de Israel supone un viraje a la
extrema derecha sin precedentes de los
120 escaños que tiene el acné set el
parlamento israelí netanyahu se llevó 64
de ellos su partido el de Cut obtuvo 32
escaños sus aliados Ultra ortodoxos 18 y
los ultranacionalistas del sionismo
religioso 14 los líderes de este último
se oponen a la creación de un estado
palestino quieren la anexión de las
discordania ocupada y en el pasado eran
antiderechos lgbtiq más uno de ellos y
tamar bengavir fue condenado en 2007 por
incitación racista contra los árabes y
apoyo al terrorismo a pesar de esto Bibi
como se le conoce dijo que haría un
gobierno para todos
el público de los votantes ha confiado
inequívocamente en mí y en mi partido
likuth así como en los partidos que se
asocian a nosotros
pero quiero decir Tengo la intención de
ser el Primer Ministro de todos de los
que me eligieron y de los que no no es
solo una forma de decirlo refleja lo que
creo en lo profundo de mi alma y lo que
guía mis acciones
pero el temor por su gestión aumenta
entre los opositores ya que la derecha
Espera a probar reformas judiciales que
son vistas como desfavorables
podría también asumir el control total
sobre el nombramiento de los jueces del
tribunal supremo desde el lado palestino
el nuevo gobierno es malpercibido en su
periodo de 12 años como Primer Ministro
aumentaron los asentamientos israelíes
en territorios ocupados tras la llegada
de vivienda Yahoo de nuevo al poder
varios países occidentales entre ellos
Estados Unidos pidieron tolerancia y
respeto a los grupos minoritarios
vamos a Colombia donde la peor temporada
de lluvias en 40 años debido a una
intensa presencia del fenómeno de la
niña Ya deja hasta el momento 205
fallecidos y medios centenar
desaparecidos las autoridades informaron
que los 32 departamentos del país se han
visto afectados entre tanto en Bogotá la
capital la alcaldesa Claudia López
decretó el estado de calamidad pública
debido a los derrumbes e inundaciones
provocados por las lluvias que según
estiman los expertos meteorológicos
podría durar podrían durar hasta febrero
en medio del verano austral
el 26 de septiembre pasado Cuba aprobó
en referendo el nuevo código de las
familias una ley impulsada por el
gobierno de Miguel Díaz canel que avala
por primera vez los matrimonios entre
personas del mismo sexo
Cuba vive una nueva Revolución esta vez
en su código de familia aprobado en
referendo en septiembre cambió la vida
de Pedro Rafael Delgado de 56 años y de
Adolfo López de 62 años por fin pudieron
casarse siempre viví
con ese rechazo con ese dolor de que tus
propias familias y fueran los que te
censuraran en octubre Se realizaron 75
matrimonios entre personas del mismo
sexo son más del 2% del total de bodas
en Estados Unidos los hogares del mismo
sexo representan el 1,5 pero activistas
consideran que todavía hay camino por
recorrer la lucha también es cultural
una vez aprobada la ley Hay que seguir
trabajando con las mentalidades para que
los prejuicios sean poco a poco
desmontados la nueva ley también cambió
la vida de Ariana mederos esta
estudiante de Medicina pensó que nunca
podría desarrollar su carrera cuando
hace unos años empezó su transición
la sociedad tiene un poco de avance que
yo lo he visto bastante marcado porque
las personas hoy como tal no se dirigen
a una persona trans como lo hacían antes
mirando sobre el ojo sobre el hombro el
referendo contó con gran publicidad y
apoyo mediático la mitad de 11 millones
de cubanos participaron en la discusión
del proyecto y tras su aprobación Cuba
se sitúa en la vanguardia de derechos
sociales emprendida antes en Argentina
Brasil Chile y Colombia
la ciudad de Nueva York sigue inmersa en
una crisis migratoria la urbe se ha
convertido en una de las principales
receptoras de personas provenientes de
Centroamérica y Suramérica Un aumento en
el flujo de viajeros que pone en jaque
su capacidad de brindar asilo Manuel acá
no tiene los detalles
la llegada de Gustavo Méndez a Nueva
York fue hospiciada por un político
republicano uno de los gobernadores de
los estados del sur le compró un billete
de bus que lo lleva al este a la ciudad
que se ha convertido en uno de los
núcleos de la migración latinoamericana
a Estados Unidos ese sabido era tan duro
la selva o aparte de la selva de
enfrentarse a los demás países
las limitaciones que te ponen que
tuvimos en Nicaragua que tuvimos en
Honduras en Guatemala
la historia de Gustavo es similar a la
de más de 17.000 personas que han
llegado en los últimos seis meses a
Nueva York provenientes especialmente de
países centroamericanos y de Venezuela
su vida en una crisis migratoria la urbe
se enfrenta a la amenaza de desbordar su
sistema de Refugio
antes de este gran aumento de
solicitantes de asilo solía haber un
periodo de esperar de entre ocho meses y
dos años preveo que con la mayor llegada
de solicitantes de asilo al menos se
doblará
la ciudad liderada por el demócrata Evil
Adams tuvo que anunciar el estado de
emergencia en octubre
y el domingo la oficina de presupuesto
independiente de Nueva York aseguró que
sus gastos anuales para brindar Refugio
educación y atención médica a los
solicitantes de asilo se estiman en 600
millones de dólares unas cifras que
según el informe no estaban
presupuestadas previamente y que
necesitarían de mayores recursos
federales y estatales para poder
enfrentar la masiva migración así
llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en Francia 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega toda la información del
continente africano en África siete días
con amal benotman feliz noche para todos
[Música]